heroes of the storm wasn't
trying to be league of legends or dota
2. it was trying to be something
different
you gotta gain xp to level as a team
there is no individual leveling done
in heroes of the storm you level as a
team you win as a team and you die as a
team
and in 2016 when blizzard announced it
was bankrolling the game's esports scene
it seemed like it could finally break
into the mainstream
i can't try to stop it but he won't be
able to ballistic
[Applause]
[Music]
but just a few years later lizard
basically gutted heroes of the storm
esports
he's the one that paused the game and
like said in all chat you know check out
your emails and then
yeah that's when we saw the announcement
we're just like well
it's been fun haunts never rose to the
heights it was supposed to
it's been called a dead game but now
a new effort is trying to change that we
would like to offer you an org slot for
ccl for your team
can i have a moment just yes yes
[Music]
in 2010 blizzard wanted to show off the
depth of starcraft's arcade a place for
players to share custom maps
so they revealed blizzard dota it was a
reference to
dota a mod for warcraft 3 that
eventually became a massively popular
moba
but development on blizzard's version
took years
eventually the game was renamed heroes
of the storm but when fans got their
hands on it in 2014
the mobile landscape had shifted league
of legends had been out for
years and already had a system built out
of regional leagues that fed into a
global championship
meanwhile dota 2 also had die hard fans
who regularly raised insane prize pools
for their big tournaments
but here's where the storm didn't try to
be either of those games
it was actually something pretty
different beyond the all-star cast of
blizzard characters from the company's
various franchises
the game itself focused more on teamwork
than individual farming
you gotta gain xp to level as a team
there is no individual leveling done in
heroes of the storm you level
as a team you win as a team and you die
as a team gold was replaced by talents
there were multiple maps and each one
had objectives to fight over that could
drastically change the course of a game
even the heroes were different blizzard
went all in on strange innovative
designs and the heroes only got
weirder as time went on the player who
picks cho
is in command of movement for both
players and thus responsible for keeping
the brothers in position
to damage enemies for tank player manny
fury medina
it was love at first sight especially
because laning took a back seat to team
fighting as soon as like you know i saw
hotz removed a lot of that stuff where
you don't have to worry too much about
last hitting and stuff like that
um it was more focused on team fighting
and your team
especially like i thought it was a
really cool idea that blizzard had but
despite all the differences between hots
and other mobas blizzards still wanted a
big esports scene
so in 2015 they began their efforts in
earnest
major esports orcs picked up their own
rosters and some even set up team houses
blizzard even dipped their toes into
collegiate esports with heroes of the
dorm a tournament where players could
win their college tuition and prizes so
when i really fell in love with heroes
of the storm was around
here's the dorm so i was going to asu i
was a freshman at the time i just
freshly got out of high school
and they announced that basically you
could win college tuition if you you
know played in heroes of the dorm
and you know my dreamy ass was like you
know what maybe i'll be able to win
that first year of heroes of the dorm
was broadcast on espn which
brought a lot of eyes and attention to
the fledgling game and
for michael udall it became a goal so
basically we lost years of the dorm the
first year in like a
clutch finals and then the following
year we didn't drop a single game the
entire season
i was kind of like the captain for the
team i was like the shot caller drafter
i think after that i gained confidence
and belief in myself that
you know what i can if i put my mind to
something i can achieve
you know i can achieve it illidan isn't
here for 15 seconds the damage now on
the court dxena trying to fly shields
akka fakes low on hp but the court
is going down
state your champions
udall went on to compete in hots esports
on some of na's biggest teams
with big prize pools a clear path to pro
and major orgs in the scene
it seemed like hauntz esports was poised
to take off in 2016 blizzard announced
that each team that competed in both
phases of the heroes global championship
would get 100 000 for player salaries
it was a 3.2 million dollar commitment
for 2017.
suddenly even the hots players who
weren't on the best teams in the world
could make a living playing the game
they loved
and for two years hgc was a stable
career path for hot players
all around the world for my case like
this is always a dream esports and then
i put in
what four plus years into like all the
progress i've made i felt like i've made
a
good name for myself i did what i always
wanted to do which was travel
compete on stages meet a bunch of fans
like do all the really fun stuff esports
stuff that i got to watch
lcs players do but not everything was as
perfect as it seemed
in 2018 plenty of orgs bowed out of the
htc
including tricked gale force esports and
space station gaming
but from the outside looking in things
seemed amazing fans were being treated
to the best hot play they'd ever seen
and blizzard was bankrolling all of it
look at it close it out sanctification
has been
has done it they are your 2018
global champions fury said that at
blizzcon 2018
blizzard told players to expect more of
the same htc in 2019
but that's not what happened so i'm sure
most of you have heard already
the wonderful news uh
hgc has been canceled and
it's some hot [ __ ] on december 13th
right in the middle of the holiday
season just days before christmas hot
players found out that
their league was dead i remember like we
were screaming against biggie
specifically and
he's the one that paused the game and
like said in all chat you know check out
your emails and then
everybody went to go check your emails
and then yeah that's when we saw the
announcement we're just like well
it's been fun and everybody just leaves
the custom game like
that was like the saddest thing ever
it's just like we're middle practicing
and then suddenly it's like well
i guess we're done yeah the moment i
found out htc was
canceled was uh was on twitter actually
it really sucked i i logged onto twitter
one day
and i basically saw that me and all my
friends and all my colleagues lost their
job
according to later reports from inven
global even people
at blizzard were blindsided by the move
i was straight up
told by blizzard employees
at blizzcon and all of tempo storm
thought this same thing
of course we thought it because we were
told that by people who work at blizzard
that the hgc was going to be
the same players had been preparing and
scrimming for htc 2019 for months
and now all that effort was just wasted
time
it it just really tore me apart to just
see
all that hard work just taken away from
me without
you know having any not even a warning
at least like we spent
we wasted literally like three months
screaming for nothing like
that that could have been three months
like preparing
what we should all be doing next around
the same time blizzard announced that
they were slowing development down on
hots
and many of the game's devs were moved
to other projects
all of a sudden hot felt like a dead
game
the last four years of my life that i
had committed and dedicated to this game
i felt like it was all a waste it wasn't
right because like
experiences in and of themselves have
value but it felt like i had been
working so hard towards something
just to have like the rug pulled out
from under me in the years after it came
out
haunts really carved out its own niche
in the esports world
but it seemed like that wasn't big
enough for blizzard and while the game
itself wasn't
actually dead there was a bit of a
public perception that hotz was
heading towards a retirement home it's
not a big game
it's just obviously htc dying was like
our esports scene like main
thing that was dead but the game was
still alive like people were still
playing it
but a community that lived for so long
in the shadow of larger games
isn't that easy to destroy two years
after
hgc was killed hauntz esports fans got
some good news
here at heroes hearth we're getting
ready to bring you back some
grassroots heroes of the storm esports
action
with the community clash league or the
ccl
in hotz's early years there were plenty
of grassroots tournaments that sprang up
to supplement blizzard's few
official offerings and now that model
became the
backbone of the ccl the thing that i
think really helps ccl stand apart
is that it's built in a sustainable
fashion right it's only gonna work if
the fans enjoy it the tournament
organizer
enjoys it the pro players enjoy it and
the orgs enjoy it and for udall
who had played dota 2 and worked full
time since the htc was cancelled
it gave him another opportunity we would
like to
offer you an org slot for ccl for your
team
can i have a moment yes yes udall became
an owner in the ccl with his new team
30k and fury was first pick in the
inaugural draft
ccl is a lot smaller than htc
but it's built to survive on the
interest that actually
does exist around the game and for hots
fans who have stayed true
all these years that's more than enough
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages
[Music]
you